und wir schauen nach großbritannien
zugunglück in schottland es sind
mindestens drei menschen ums leben
gekommen viele weitere wurden verletzt
der zug entgleiste nach starken
regenfällen nahe der stadt stonehaven
vermutlich hatte das unwetter einen
erdrutsch ausgelöst das triebfahrzeug
stürzte mit drei seiner vier waggons
eine böschung hinunter wenige stunden
zuvor hatte der betreiber der bahn scott
rail selbst noch vor überflutungen in
der region gewarnt
ja und der britische premierminister
boris johnson äußerte sich zu dem
unglück per twitter es erfüllt mich mit
trauer von dem sehr ernsten unfall in
aberdeen zu hören und meine gedanken
sind bei den betroffenen und ich danke
den rettungskräften vor ort